okay okay
we have an update for you mega millions
a lot of people playing a lot of money
on the line michelle has won
four dollars
four dollars
one number and the mega million four
bucks that's two more tickets you have a
189 chance to win what she wants right
and your books four bucks i won
i'm a winner you are a winner how does
it feel what are you gonna do four
dollars
i'll buy what
two more tickets three more tickets two
more tickets more tickets i thought they
were three dollars not my thing but
definitely not me well
let's go
well if you want money in mega millions
like me you'll be ordering lots of stuff
and this week amazon announced it will
begin making deliveries by drone in two
cities in texas and california in the
coming months and now amazon is already
facing some unfriendly skies competition
from other drone delivery services that
are just now getting off the ground
chris van cleave has the story
the future has landed in tom kulas's
frisco texas driveway he's among the
very first in the lone star state to get
a delivery from a drone you ordered ice
cream and if you had done that through
like a door dash or an uber eats or any
of the food delivery services
that would have taken
20 30 minutes easily it was here in five
that's absolutely right
that's a lot faster totally faster and
better quality product it's not melted
wing owned by google's parent company
alphabet just launched in suburban
dallas
and there's already competition about 90
minutes away flytrax is focusing on
granberry with drones dropping off
coffee in matt barthelo's backyard see
if it's still warm
it's hot it's hot it's hot yeah for now
drone delivery is free users order from
an app a worker gets the item loads and
launches the drone which is monitored by
an faa certified operator this gives
people quicker access to goods in a
highly efficient manner jonathan bass
from wing health care items medications
food
we've delivered you know coveted tests
wings drones are designed and built in
the u.s they can carry about three
pounds a company study estimates in the
dallas area alone drones could deliver
about two percent of all purchased items
around 200 million in sales saving
people 39 hours of errand running a year
we're
expecting to take some of these packages
that would have been delivered by you
know a 12 000 pound truck and instead
deliver it with a 10-pound aircraft and
the huge advantage there that we see is
a large reduction in carbon emissions
as well as an increase in safety by
year's end walmart plans to add drone
delivery in six states and amazon aims
to launch its own drone fleet starting
in california tom kulas hopes it really
takes off i think
the faster we get something the better
delivered right to you
right away for cbs saturday morning i'm
chris van cleave in frisco texas
my one question would be the weight of
packages because can you imagine looking
around and you see all these like huge
packages
in the but you like the idea you you
actually said you're not sure if you
want ice cream the ice cream part i
would delivered no ice cream or coffee
you think the coffee would spill right
yeah so some things on that feels a
little too late yeah although the coffee
is a really good thing on my list to
have delivered to my front door
make it in the pot just make it i don't
have a kitchen right now
that would be a problem yeah
that's a story for another time